un complejo de apartamentos de 15
plantas destruido por los bombardeos los
servicios de emergencia dicen que los
cuerpos fueron sacados de los escombros
de este edificio en el oeste de kiev
justo al lado del suburbio de irbin
donde se produjeron algunos de los
combates más encarnizados
en un distrito vecino los residentes y
las fuerzas de seguridad examinan los
daños de otro edificio atacado a primera
hora del martes
encontrando restos de artillería entre
los escombros
es posible hacer esto para más agradezco
a los vecinos que ayudaron a evacuar a
mis negras rápidamente ahora está en mi
coche sana y salva todo el mundo está a
salvo gracias a dios en este edificio
todo el mundo está bien nadie ha
resultado herido directo en mi pasta
una serie de explosiones sacudieron la
capital antes del amanecer una de ellas
captada aquí en el vídeo un destello de
luz seguido de una explosión
[Música]
se está convirtiendo en un patrón varios
murieron en ataques similares en
edificios en las primeras horas del
lunes para algunos del miedo ha dado
paso a la ira este hombre ayuda a sus
vecinos a cargar su coche mientras huyen
al campo
porque todas estas bombas sobre nosotros
esto no es la guerra la guerra es una
batalla entre soldados no es esconderse
detrás de los arbustos y amenazar a todo
el mundo
más de la mitad de los habitantes de
kiev han huido desde el comienzo de la
ofensiva rusa este grupo de refugiados
acaba de llegar tras huir de los
combates más al este
la carretera estaba llena de minas nos
quedamos con los niños
y ahora somos hermanas fue un infierno
i
un infierno del que aún no han escapado
con las tropas rusas acercándose a la
capital cada día